is it always 2:30 it's always 2:30 you
want to show everybody why it's time to
go to the dentist to pretty that exists
just for this joke yep
good morning John I'm here with Tessa
violet musician and singer and
songwriter and friend of mine we're
gonna do this there's a Wikipedia page
called Wikipedia unusual articles I'm
obsessed with this page I don't know who
curates it or how it gets made I found
out about this list from window
reproductions he does a series on this
page but I thought that we would just
take five minutes
scroll through pick one each and then
teach each other about the bizarre
reality of the world there was once a
place I think it's still a place called
the holla ha grab re it was the only
third-order enclave what does that mean
it sounds pretty creepy right but it's
not that creepy but it is very weird it
was a piece of India within a piece of
Bangladesh that was within a piece of
India that was within a piece of
Bangladesh Wow so when they made the the
border between India and Bangladesh
there were lots of places where there
were like Indian people living inside
everything although maybe it was bad
well it turned out that it was
complicated and difficult to manage this
one was 7,000 square meters little less
than two acres difficult to like provide
services for the people who lived there
he started to basically swap them until
they had no enclaves and that was in
2015 so this was relatively recently
that they that they finally that's what
do you have for me I've got a cool
tempest prognosticator yep that's
probably how you say that the year is
the nineteenth century the century is
1842 its 1850 and oh my gosh that was
pretty close inventor dr. Merryweather
invents this thing to tell whether or
not a storm is coming and he uses 12
leeches you know as you can see it's
setup and sort of a round like a
carousel of leeches yes leeches I guess
crawl upward and out of the way
when they sense a storm is coming really
the leeches crawl up and they knock like
into a tube and they knock a whale bone
out which rings a bell and it was pretty
accurate Wow
now of course we've got all the
satellites and we've got barometric
pressure and all that jazz but we didn't
have that so instead it was like well
the leeches no yeah the leeches have
satellites there sorry to leech their
own I don't know how to compete with
that it's really pretty is this an
actual picture of it yeah this is a
replication and those are real leeches
inside you don't think so
where do you get leeches now I don't
know then ain't from any doctor yours
was better than mine that was so good I
control EFT for framing meteorology by
frightened an alien annelid which is the
worm how's my book oh it's so good she
got a couple my book it's so freakin
good I'm not much of a reader
I've reading a bit of a chore for me I
very rarely finished books even books
that I like oh I've started Sunday today
is Monday and I'm three-quarters through
it and I was walking down the street
reading it because I couldn't put it
down
thanks for joining me thank you for
watching and for saving Tessa's new
single crush on Spotify or watching it
on YouTube or wherever digital musics
are found I like it a lot I can't wait
for the full album to come out it's so
good John I'll see you on Tuesday
I remember you reached out to me and you
were like hey do you want to host this
show it's trivia really you have a green
screen and I was like mom agreed emailed
me